both of its wings have transparent
windows crystal duck
open the southern borders
[Music]
i feel like i want to jump out of my own
skin
i just
that's the type of thought that runs
through my brain when i feel overloaded
over stimulated
when i'm jacked in
keeping up with every little thing
that's going on in the world
it's like a pressure
the tension
caving in my skull that's good just keep
rubbing your head i nurse on the input
like a newborn
it's the first thing i reach for when i
wake
the last thing i look at before i sleep
and yeah i know it's not good
i'd rather be doing something else
but i can't help but feel that if i let
it go i'll miss something
i'll feel disconnected
alone
but the pressure builds
this extension of myself
it revs my mind up
and it doesn't stop it's like i'm
looking for
something one thing that i've started to
notice
is that whenever i cut myself off from
the feed
when i choose to be alone
when i seek stillness
i find it
and this feeling i was running from was
what i was searching for
life is often exactly as simple as we
need it to be
there's nothing complicated about a
flowing stream
a crackling fire
a cloudy day
unless of course we make it that way
[Music]
we can always analyze life
cerebralize it theorize about it if we
need to
but how often do we need to
are things not also meant to be
experienced for what they are as they
are
because obviously thinking about things
and analyzing reality helps us
understand it
but when we live in our heads
it distorts reality
we start looking with our minds instead
of our eyes
the mountains don't care what we think
of them
[Applause]
there's a quote by gk chesterton that's
always stuck with me goes like this
it is an act of faith to assert that our
thoughts have any relation to reality at
all if you're merely a skeptic you must
sooner or later ask yourself the
question
why should anything go right
even observation and deduction
why should not good logic be as
misleading as bad logic they are both
movements in the brain of a bewildered
ape i always thought this quote was
pretty funny and it does a great job of
reminding us that what happens inside
our brains may not be as sophisticated
as we probably think we tend to
celebrate the human mind as the pinnacle
of intelligence
yet when we spend too much time in there
we become anxious and isolated why is
that
why is it that the most common piece of
advice that you might hear for someone
who's socially anxious needlessly
vengeful or compulsively conspiratorial
is get out of your head it's like we all
instinctively know that there's a
disconnect between reality itself and
our interpretation of it and when we
spend too much time untethered from the
world as it is and instead filter our
experiences through references and
distortions isn't it obvious that the
resulting effect is disorientation is it
not obvious that when we plug ourselves
into sources that profit off stirring up
fear and dread within us that we would
feel more worried and dreadful i always
find it hilarious it'll be a beautiful
day outside the most peaceful divine
reality before us but we'll be on
youtube or twitter or reddit and
there'll be some world event that
usually has nothing to do with us and
we'll go that's terrible man the world
is [ __ ] up and then we look out the
window at the glorious sun piercing
through the clouds over a rolling
landscape and instead of wonder or awe
or gratitude we think would i survive a
nuclear winter i'll leave you guys with
a quote
marcus aurelius said that if you're
distressed by anything external the pain
is not due to the thing itself but to
your estimate of it and this you have
the power to revoke at any moment
yeah i'm feeling really good guys
honestly i feel like there's a
one-to-one relationship between my
mental health and the amount of time i
spend on social media or just like in
front of any kind of screen for any
reason whatsoever it always pays off to
just spend time away from my computer
from my phone and recently i've been
going to the gym way more often i've
been spending time outside and i've
really started to just nail simple daily
habits that make me feel really good and
a habit that's been extremely important
in my life over the past like two years
or so is also the sponsor of today's
video and that is taking athletic greens
a big thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video as i've talked
about before i've been taking athletic
greens for like two years now and i
actually reached out to them and asked
them if they want to be a sponsor of
this channel because i take their stuff
every day and it's a huge contributor to
my overall physical and mental health
because there's basically no competing
with the amount of vitamins and
nutrients that are absolutely jam-packed
into one scoop of this stuff there are
75 vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens in
one convenient daily serving ag-1
supports your energy focus gut health
digestion immunity and mental clarity
without the need to take multiple
products or pills athletic greens uses
these whole foods and natural sources
and condenses them into this fine powder
which you scoop up you add to water and
you drink it and i've tried so many
different greens powders and potions and
weird stuff over the years and out of
all of them this one by far tastes the
best so it's just a very pleasant way to
start off your morning with the
confidence that you're giving your body
all the tools that it needs to be filled
with energy and to perform optimally
throughout the day so if you're
interested in joining me in this very
simple daily health optimization habit
which i've been partaking in for about
two years now use my link in the
description below and you'll also get a
year's supply of the vitamin d3 and k2
complex which i also use every single
morning as well as five ag-1 travel
packs with your first purchase so once
again if you're interested in ag-1 use
my link in the description below to get
a year's supply of the vitamin d3 and k2
complex as well as five ag-1 travel
packs with your first purchase thanks
again athletic greens for sponsoring
this video and if you like this video
make sure that you actually hit the like
button because when you hit the like
button the algorithm blesses me by
shoving my bald head into other people's
home pages helping them out which also
helps me out so it's just a win-win for
everybody if you just click that like
button and if you're lurking here
consider subscribing and checking out
the second channel which has been fairly
inactive as of late but i post some
goodies on there sometimes um i'll also
be releasing the fact that i got a po
box and i know some people want to send
me some stuff and i'll do an unboxing on
there and it'll be super fun so yeah
just subscribe to the second channel to
stay tuned for that other than that
thank you so much for watching go touch
grass and i'll catch you in the next
video
foreign